les voisins joués de certains petits
cymars cachent depuis longtemps un
secret lui rapporter avant le tourbillon
de la célébrité quatre d’entre eux se
sont retrouvés à l'orphelinat de
Chicoutimi au moment où leur mère et
leur frère René étaient hospitalisés et
leur père incapables de s'occuper d'eux
vos parents malades vous allez payer
pour vous et ils ont tenu parole ils
sont battus les sœurs franciscaines leur
font vivre un calvaire cette descente
aux enfers laisse des séquelles je
voulais me tuer j'avais essayé d'en-tête
d'oreiller puis respirer tout le temps
tout le temps ils m'ont rempli ça
il faut tout que tu marches
c'est atroce c'est un des deux mots à
bien religieux
ça vient me chercher
Monique Fortin a vécu 12 longues années
à l'orphelinat et raconte avoir été
agressé sexuellement
des survivants et d'anciens employés
auraient vu des femmes de Dieu commettre
des réparables une religieuse a poussé
une petite fille après le mur c'est
sûrement involontaire mais le geste on a
vu par après le surlendemain deux jours
la petite est décédée est exposée notre
lingerie alors felinat djouville à
Québec et à celui de Burlington au
Vermont d'autres religieuses auraient
aussi fait des victimes qui attendent
toujours des excuses de l'église les
congrégations visées contestent
toutefois ces allégations ici Priscilla
Plamondon la lancette Radio-Canada SAG